[Music]
this episode and others like it are made
possible by the generous support of my
patrons on patreon
if you'd like to help support my channel
and get early access to every video
consider becoming a patron at
patreon.com
second thought to the rest of the world
the us is known for a few things
obesity disney world and our massive
military
to many countries the population's only
experience with americans is through
violent occupation and imperialism
we operate no fewer than 1 000 military
bases
600 of them overseas ready to threaten
whatever part of the world we see fit
the u.s spends more money on the
military than the next 10 nations
combined
and the country has been engaged in
conflict in 93
of all the years since its founding the
united states is an exceptionally
warlike nation
those in power tried to cast our
military actions as defensive
even going so far as to rename the
department of war to the department of
defense
but the truth of the matter is that war
is one of our biggest industries
we sell weapons to some of the most
oppressive regimes in the world
including ourselves we rely on foreign
intervention to bolster the economy
plundering resources leveling cities so
we can send in teams of contractors to
rebuild them
launching ridiculous propaganda
campaigns to condition the u.s
population for another cold war to
maintain our economic stranglehold on
the entire planet
the rest of the world with very few
exceptions despises our military
a growing number of americans realize
that our military action is not
defensive
but oppressive surely there are better
ways to spend the ridiculous sums of
money we dump into never-ending war
in this episode we'll take a look at the
u.s military budget and determine what
programs we could fund with just a
sliver of that funding
let's start with some numbers while we
don't yet know the exact defense budget
for fiscal year 2022
it's looking like the base budget will
be somewhere in the 704 to 708 billion
range roughly the same as the previous
years this is despite the fact that the
democrats want to paint themselves as
less warlike than the republicans
and that progressives have been calling
for major cuts to military spending
of course in reality the democrats are
not any less warlike than the
republicans
they've simply rebranded themselves as
woke imperialists
so biden's military budget matching
trumps should not come as a surprise
to keep things simple let's assume a
nice round figure of 700 billion
this massive sum funds a number of
different projects research development
and procurement of new weapon systems
paying military personnel operations and
maintenance
and becoming more and more expensive
with each administration paying private
contractors to do the military's job
without supervision or even much
regulation
the pentagon budget has been trending
upwards for years reportedly due to the
desire to keep up with china's increase
in spending
which grows by roughly six and a half
percent each year of course
this ignores the fact that we could
literally cut our defense budget in half
and we'd still be spending a hundred
billion dollars more per year than china
just like in the first cold war the
existence of another economic superpower
makes for great propaganda to convince
americans it's a good idea to dump more
money into our industrial war machine
now 700 billion dollars is a massive
figure
it's too big for most of us to even wrap
our head around so
let's break it down to a monthly budget
the pentagon spends roughly 60 billion
dollars per month on war and the
maintenance of global domination
60 billion is still a ridiculous sum but
at least it's a slightly smaller number
to work with
so what could we do with just one month
of the us military budget
we face a huge number of challenges here
at home which is part of the reason it's
so infuriating when our tax dollars go
towards blowing up innocent people
in other countries we face a
homelessness crisis with over half a
million americans without so much as a
roof over their heads
and that was before the pandemic and the
waves of eviction still looming over
millions of families
we have the most expensive colleges and
universities in the world
our students are underperforming
compared to other nations and
enter the workforce with tremendous debt
more than any previous generation
we're the only industrialized nation not
to offer some kind of universal health
care
despite being the richest nation on
earth instead
our healthcare is the most expensive and
least effective among peer nations
inequality in the u.s has gotten so bad
that life expectancy among the working
class is going down
while the rich get richer and their life
expectancy continues to trend
upwards housing has become completely
unaffordable to most americans
there's not a single county in the u.s
where a minimum wage earner can afford a
one-bedroom apartment
this is despite the fact that we have a
huge surplus of homes
there are currently somewhere around 17
million vacant homes in the u.s
we keep building them but no one can
afford them these are just a small
sample of the problems average americans
face in their daily lives
so let's see what we can do with a slice
of the war budget we'll start with
homelessness
according to one government report it
would cost 20 billion dollars to end
homelessness for good
not 20 billion dollars per year a
one-time investment of 20 billion
we could end homelessness permanently
for one-third
of one month of the u.s military budget
that sounds like a bargain to me
why keep indefinitely spending small
sums of money that just paper over the
problem
when we could bite the bullet drop one
last lump sum of money and completely
eradicate
the homelessness crisis the fact that we
have so many people without the basic
necessity of shelter
is a national embarrassment and is in
direct contrast with the myth that the
us is the greatest nation on earth
if we can't even provide for the most
basic needs of our people
what good are we frankly we should put
an end to homelessness simply because
it's the right thing to do
but since this is america we're talking
about a one-time investment of 20
billion dollars will save us money in
the long run
the federal government spends just shy
of three billion dollars per year on
funding programs that address
homelessness
a little quick math should tell you that
a one-time investment would pay for
itself in just seven years
that's just good business sense there is
absolutely no reason we couldn't end
homelessness this year
it would just require a shifting of our
priorities away from violence and
oppression abroad
towards decency and compassion at home
let's take another challenge
universal health care it's not uncommon
to see americans saddled with tens or
even hundreds of thousands of dollars in
medical debt
we have the most expensive health care
in the world by far
on average our per capita expenditure on
health care is eleven thousand dollars
fully twice the comparable country
average okay but we get great care for
that price right
well not exactly among our peer nations
our healthcare metrics are objectively
worst in most categories
among these categories are critical
factors like infant mortality and life
expectancy at birth
to make matters worse we are the only
developed nation that doesn't provide
universal health care to our citizens
so in other wealthy nations and even
many less developed ones
you can walk into a doctor's office or
hospital receive treatment
and walk out without paying a cent
that's all taken care of by reasonable
taxes
in the u.s we still pay taxes but that
money goes to things like bombs and
overthrowing democratically elected
governments in the global south
instead of having our health care
guaranteed to all we instead have to
shoulder tremendously expensive medical
bills
even if we have supposedly good
employer-provided health care
if you don't have health insurance good
luck there's a reason so many americans
choose not to get the care they need
it's because they simply can't afford it
okay by this point in the year of our
lord 2021
everyone should know that the us
healthcare system is objectively
terrible
it would make a whole lot more sense to
do what all the other wealthy countries
do
and implement a universal health care
system so what's it gonna cost
according to a congressional budget
office report the most thorough and
extensive of its kind
we need to consider not what it will
cost to implement but how much we'll
save by implementing it
the report is incredibly comprehensive
and if you'd like to read it yourself
i've left a link in the description
but the bottom line is this the report
took four proposed universal healthcare
plans and ran the numbers
they found that every single one of them
would save us tens or hundreds of
billions of dollars per year
ranging from 42 billion to 743 billion
then just to show the most extreme end
of implementation costs
they developed a fifth hypothetical
system a program with high payment rates
to providers and drug companies
and low cost sharing for individuals and
added long-term support and services
even under this unrealistic model
spending only increased by 290 billion
per year
less than half of what we spend on death
and destruction every year
of course no one is suggesting we
implement this needlessly expensive
approach
the model that most closely matches
current medicare for all proposals would
yield 300 billion dollars in annual
savings
that sounds pretty good at this point
the only people who are against
universal healthcare are those who have
been paid to spout private insurance
propaganda
and those who have taken their bait
universal healthcare has strong
bipartisan support
there are zero benefits to private
health insurance the wait time argument
is objectively false
we wait just as long for treatment as
many countries with universal health
care
plus we pay obscene amounts of money to
do it but just for the sake of this
thought experiment
let's say we did adopt the unreasonably
expensive model the one that adds 290
billion dollars to the annual cost of
healthcare
if we take that number plus the 20
billion for ending homelessness
we still haven't even reached 50 percent
of what the pentagon spent on war every
single year
and we've solved two of the biggest
challenges facing the american people
now all of this sounds great but the
politicians aren't just going to concede
to common sense
they're invested often quite literally
in the never-ending growth of the
military
part of the problem is the continued
privatization of all aspects of modern
life under capitalism
we now have fewer active military
personnel than private contractors in
the middle east
we are addicted to outsourcing labor to
the private sector
often with disastrous consequences one
of those consequences is that the
department of defense will face years of
litigation and hundreds of millions of
dollars in settlements if they attempt
to pull american operatives out of
afghanistan
why because the u.s had signed an
agreement to fully withdraw from
afghanistan by may 1st of 2021
but there are still thousands of active
contractors in that country with
contracts that don't expire until well
after the withdrawal deadline
if the u.s pulls them out before their
contracts expire
the pentagon would face tremendous
backlash from these private groups
the pentagon put themselves in this
situation many of those contracts were
signed after the withdrawal deadline was
established
of course that's only one minor symptom
but it's indicative of the larger
disease
we've allowed capitalism so much free
reign that the federal government itself
along with the most powerful military in
the world is completely beholden to the
private sector
free market evangelists call for more
military funding which is then siphoned
off into the bank accounts of private
contractors who then hold the government
hostage for more funding
and on and on in a vicious cycle
enriching private interests and fueling
the cancerous growth of the
military-industrial complex
this year's defense budget will be over
700 billion dollars
after all the little extra expenses and
pet projects are tacked on
that number will be closer to
three-quarters of a trillion dollars
according to the media and government
officials our largest supposed threats
are china and russia
again if we cut our military budget in
half
we would still spend 100 billion dollars
more than china
we'd spend 300 billion more than russia
at what point do we say enough is enough
let's spend that money fixing problems
at home not making more problems abroad
martin luther king jr once said that the
united states is the greatest exporter
of violence in the world
that statement has never been more true
every year it becomes clearer that the
us military is not a force for good or
for freedom
but a force for chaos and oppression of
people you and i will never meet
people who are just like us and who do
not deserve to be brutalized
by a country who fancies itself the
world's police force we need to divest
from the military
and invest in critical projects right
here at home healthcare
ending homelessness and poverty
providing free education to our students
and making this country the nation it
claims to be
i mentioned at the beginning of this
video that this type of content is made
possible by my patrons on patreon
this kind of video while very important
is something that sponsors won't touch
to keep my channel running i rely on
sponsors adsense and donations from
generous viewers
by producing explicitly anti-capitalist
content i lose out on both sponsors and
adsense
if you'd like to help me produce more
content like this and you're able to
chip in even a dollar a month
i would greatly appreciate the support
you can find my patreon page
get early access to every video and join
our growing discord server at
patreon.com
second thought if you enjoyed this video
consider dropping a like
if you hated it a thumbs down you can
check out my previous videos by clicking
the links on your screen
thanks for watching and i'll see you
next week